[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique magazine dédié
aux élections aux élections municipales
chaque mardi en direct 18h45 je recevrai
l'un des candidats têtes de liste ce
soir olivier paréja pour décidons
ensemble pour guyancourt bonsoir et
bienvenue et vous êtes élu au sein du
conseil municipal depuis 2014 petite
précision pour débuter et bien qu'élu à
la base sur la liste de la majorité
actuelle
aujourd'hui vous avez pris vos distances
avec cette majorité alors c'est pas
aujourd'hui ça fait quand même quelques
quelques années puisque effectivement
progressivement en est autant j'étais
tout à fait en phase 2 en 2014 avec
françois de ligne et la liste qui l'a
mené au temps progressivement nous nous
sommes écartés on arrive j'ai été un peu
écarté on va dire de de la gestion de la
majorité municipale et de fait je n'ai
pas voté pour marie-christine le tarnec
puis françois morteau comme maire de
guyancourt configuration assez inédite
sur cette commune au cours de ce mandat
il ya eu trois maires successifs le
départ de françois de ligne et
marie-christine des tarnais qui a été
élu vous l'avez rappelé et puis elle a
dû quitter aussi pour raisons de santé
cette écharpe tricolore à la du lard
andré-françois mortes ont donc été élus
ça explique uniquement votre prise de
distance justement vous avez
l'impression qui a eu un peu de c'était
difficile cet équilibre au sein de la
majorité sur ce mandat
non je pense que en fait moi ce que
j'espérais c'est qu'à chaque élection
mer on puisse de nouveau se mettent à
retravailler ensemble
et de fait ça n'a pas été le cas et du
coup on n'a pas réussi à tirer les
sujets qui - m'intéressait qui sont plus
de participation des citoyens et
répondre à l'urgence écologique est donc
dans ces deux cas j'ai pas je ne me suis
pas retrouvé donc en l'occurrence ce qui
explique que notre position aujourd'hui
et pourtant vous avez même sensibilité
de gauche malgré tout écologiste avant
tout c'est à dire
en fait moi personnellement j'ai été un
moment et je ne le suis plus chez europe
ecologie les verts je reste écologistes
je reste attaché à la démocratie et en
particulier la démocratie participative
c'est à dire que ce que ce que
j'aimerais arriver à faire c'est c'est
dépassé les parties on a bien vu aux
dernières élections que encore la moitié
des gens ne votent pas donc c'est que le
système parti ne fonctionne plus et un
moment il faut trouver autre chose et le
fait d'utiliser les élections
municipales qui sont une élection locale
où chacun peut s'impliquer
c'est une façon de redonner accès à tout
le monde à la politique aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas encarté à l'eau qui montait
votre liste n'aura aucune investiture
olemps soutien de partis politiques
notre projet est très clair depuis le
début il est participatif écologistes
sociale et solidaire et hors partis
politiques donc d'où le nom décidons
ensemble pour guyancourt avec cette
démarche à guyancourt 10,7 des marchés
est plutôt du coup particulière il n'y
avait pas de candidats lors de la
désignation de la tête de liste ont
peut-être revenir sur cet épisode
comment vous vous êtes retrouvé malgré
tout tête de liste alors déjà la
démarche elle et elle est réfléchie et
depuis un certain temps on l'a préparé
ce qu'on a vu en avait et on l'a
distribué dans un tract qui expliquait
un peu notre processus en fait depuis le
début de l'année fin de l'année dernière
très précisément on a expliqué qu'on
allait d'abord construire le programme
donc faire des ateliers dans les rues
faire des ateliers participatifs ouvert
à tout le monde
puis le 12 octobre enfin l'assemblée où
une trentaine de personnes ont pu
débattre du programme prioriser les
idées et seulement ensuite une fois
qu'on s'était mis d'accord que le
collectif se crée autour d'une idée
autour d'un programme
à ce moment là on désigne et ben la
liste qui portera et du coup les gens
qui sont venus pour construire le
programme et on a eu des gens qui nous
ont rejoints tout au long du processus
eh ben c'est ces gens là qui vont
constituer la liste et donc du coup on a
fait c'est ce que vous rappelez le 5
novembre on a fait donc une élection
sans candidat ça veut dire que au lieu
d'avoir des gens qui disent moi je moi
je moi je
eh bien on est plutôt dans une mode où
chacun dit et bien moi je pense à
une personne moi je pense à une autre
personne pour tel et tel raison après
avoir défini les qualités et les
compétences et le mandat qu'on donne à
ces personnes là donc on a défini notre
début de liste on va dire et du coup une
petite dizaine de personnes ont émergé
et ensuite
donc là il y avait une cinquantaine de
personnes dans cette assemblée
une dizaine de personnes ont émergé et
parmi ces dix personnes là quatre
étaient plus ou moins imaginer pour être
tête de liste il se trouve qu'il y avait
quatre hommes deux hommes deux femmes et
ensuite dans une deuxième partie on a
convergé et j'ai la chance d'avoir été
désigné et vous allez mener ce ce combat
cette campagne en tout cas ensemble
malgré tout l'hexagone présentement vous
ce soir effectivement il n'avait demandé
que l'on puisse participer que nos amis
aux deux puis êtes avec moi ici pour
représenter en fait cette cette volonté
qu'on avait d'être collectif et de pas
faire une tête de liste qui prend toute
la classe récit ce que vous êtes venu
seul puisque nous avons fixé les règles
dès le début pour cette émission de
faire venir les têtes de liste ça reste
malgré tout le système aujourd'hui même
s'il a ses limites
aujourd'hui la liste définitive complète
en tout cas non à l'issue de cette
journée fait cette soirée du 5 novembre
on a en gros une vingtaine de personnes
c'est à dire qu'on est passé quand même
en construisant le programme avec des
nouvelles personnes qui arrivent à
chaque fois on est passé de 0 personnes
à 20 personnes dans la soirée sur la
liste donc ça veut dire qu'il reste
encore une quinzaine de deux personnes
qui peuvent encore nous rejoindre pour
constituer cette liste là on a encore le
temps et on est encore jusqu'à février
pour la dépose et donc il n'y a aucune
urgence
on est tout à fait optimiste n'y a aucun
souci concernant le programme puisque
vous aviez parlé d' élaborer ce
programme avant même de désigner des
candidats
aujourd'hui le programme lui où on est
il alors le programme on a fait une
première assemblée donc où on a pu
utiliser toute la matière qui venait des
ateliers participatifs qu'on avait fait
on avait en gros entre 200 idées on va
dire et du coup on a pu les les évoquer
avec tout le monde puisque tout le monde
n'était pas tous les ateliers
on a pu les compléter et ensuite on a pu
voter chacun l'a pu s'exprimer pour
voter et ils faire un ordre un petit peu
sur le programme donc assez logiquement
tout ce qui tourne autour de la
relocalisation de l'alimentation autour
de l'aménagement autour du logement
autour des solidarités sont des sujets
où les mobilités sont des sujets qui
sont qui sont ressortis avec un certain
nombre de voix et des idées et donc du
coup maintenant il nous reste est
toujours sous forme de d'ateliers qui
sont ouverts systématiquement par
exemple notre assemblée pour désigner
not least on l'a fait de façon ouverte
il y avait des affiches dans parts
partout dans guyancourt des journalistes
étaient présents pour voir le déroulé de
la soirée donc on n'est pas dans une
désignation par un parti politique en
dehors de guyancourt on n'est pas dans
une désignation du style homme
providentiel qui arrive on est vraiment
dans quelque chose de collectif ouvert
est complètement transparent il ya
plusieurs réunions qui sont programmés
21 novembre sur le thème de la
démocratie participative 3 décembre sur
l'eau sl janvier sur le nouveau quartier
des savoirs qui est prévue à la place de
l'ancien site de thalès ça représente
une trentaine d'hectares à aménager un
mot tout même sur vous également puisque
malgré tout vous êtes donc tête de liste
vous avez été élu donc sur la liste
aujourd'hui majoritaires on l'a dit vous
avez pris vos distances si vous êtes
aussi un militant associatif
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui membre de plusieurs
associations à tout à fait tout à fait
enfin et je pense que c'est ça fait
partie des choses qui sont extrêmement
importantes c'est-à-dire est à la fois
dans les institutions suit lui à lui en
cours je suis allé au lude élu à la
communauté d'agglomération mais en même
temps dans un certain nombre de
collectifs sur sur l'agriculture sur les
déplacements à vélo contre la pub
l'agression publicitaire donc mais l'un
nourrit l'autre et c'est assez logique
de continuer à fonctionner comme ça
aujourd'hui dans cette démarche vous
associer les citoyens démarche
participative
est-ce que vous avez des discussions
aussi avec les autres représentants
malgré tout politique dans le cadre
d'alliances éventuellement au sein de la
commune et puis au delà de la commune
on le sait aujourd'hui lorsqu'on vote on
voit également pour désigner des élus
communautaires pour ensuite désigné une
majorité au sein de la communauté
d'agglomération là à saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez déjà des discussions dans
d'autres communes au sein même de la
commune avec des représentants
politiques alors on a absolument aucune
discussion avec des représentants
politiques puisque notre démarche est
vraiment hors parti politique ce qu'il
veut pas dire que les gens qui nous
rejoignent ne peuvent pas être dans un
parti politique mais ça les regarde
et ça n'a rien à voir avec notre
démarche donc nous n'avons pas de
discussions avec les partis politiques
et au niveau de saint quentin il ya
plusieurs autres communes ou des listes
participative se sont montées on a
organisé ensemble la venue d'un certain
nombre de personnes commune christian
proust qui a écrit un livre sur osez
s'impliquer dans la vie politique locale
comme ivan brun skis le maire des
molières qui a aussi vu lancer un appel
le à ce que les citoyens prennent les
communes donc on a fait venir des gens
semblent donc il ya un certain nombre de
listes dans l'agglomération avec
lesquels on discute et on est sur les
mêmes valeurs et si vous siéger au sein
de la communauté d'agglomération si vous
êtes élu maire si votre liste
l'emportent
il faudra malgré tout faire à une union
une alliance enfin on n'est pas obligé
non plus de faire une alliance on peut
imaginer que y ait une place pour des
listes participative et que ça constitue
en soi un groupe merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur ce plateau olivier paréja donc
représentant de cette liste et décidons
ensemble à guyancourt
je rappelle que sur cette commune se
présente également françois morton le
maire sortant divers gauche grégory pape
soutenu par la république en marche et
puis rodolphe le baril là sans étiquette
mais soutenu par le mouvement génération
terrain merci à vous et nous vous
suivrons bien évidemment cette campagne
sur guyancourt comme sur les autres
communes du département
merci
nous partons à présent pour elle en
cours ou la liste citoyenne réinventons
elancourt a désigné sa tête de liste là
aussi il s'agit de catherine perrotin
raufast médecin de famille membres de
l'école de musique
elle réside depuis 30 ans dans cette
commune son lancement de campagne a eu
lieu le 16 novembre dernier reportage
aurait les rondes c'est elle qui
conduira la liste et réinventant
elancourt aux prochaines élections
municipales élan courtoise depuis plus
de 30 ans catherine perrotin raufast et
médecins le collectif qui l'a désigné
est composé de militants politiques
associatifs et de citoyen elancourt que
j'aime beaucoup c'est ma ville a
beaucoup changé et l'encours est devenue
une ville morne endormi où il ne se
passe plus rien
pour moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que les habitants puissent reprendre en
main leur ville
réinventons et l'encours est une liste
participative qui défendent des valeurs
de gauche
pour cette nouvelle réunion près de 80
personnes avaient fait le déplacement à
la maison de quartier de la ville dieu
c'est l'avenir c'est ce que les gens
recherchent en ce moment ils en ont
marre des prises de décisions
centralisée donc ils ont besoin d'avoir
un tracteur de leur propre destin et de
leurs décisions
donc c'est l'intérêt de ces listes que
tout le monde puisse y trouver son
compte et avoir un vrai intérêt à y
participer
je suis dans les jardins familiaux des
quatre arbres qui sont menacées de
destruction depuis plusieurs années par
la mairie et là j'ai trouvé une liste
qui s'engagent à les préserver et même à
les agrandir donc c'était la raison du
pourquoi je suis venu cet après midi
même si le programme est encore en cours
d'élaboration les principaux ponts
étaient présentés lors de cette réunion
tous nos axes c'est démocratie
participative transition écologique est
une ville pour tous les âges pour tous
les quartiers pour tous les besoins
autre projet évoqué l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt dans une perspective
verte ou encore une gestion raisonnée le
modem annonce de nouveaux et soutien à
des candidats à travers la france et
notamment dans les yvelines la plupart
du temps les soutiens se portent sur des
candidats déjà investi par la république
en marche à carrières sous poissy ou
encore à à triel-sur-seine on notera
kottmann un instrument que des
républicains a lui aussi soutenu par le
parti de françois bayrou à trappes
l'actuel conseiller municipal
d'opposition
il a déjà été rejoint également par le
représentant local du modem benoît corde
quelques dates à présent avant de
refermer cette édition est tout d'abord
aux clayes-sous-bois le candidat divers
gauche nicolas huot conseiller municipal
d'opposition poursuit ses réunions
publiques le 28 novembre ce sera dans le
quartier ouest de l a ville et puis à
montigny le bretonneux le collectif
citoyen msp pour alternative
iny montagne écologiques et solidaires
poursuit la constitution de sa liste là
aussi participative avec une nouvelle
réunion ce 27 novembre à noter qu
officiellement aucun nom ne quand deux
candidats n'a encore été donné sur cette
commune
rendez vous mardi prochain 26 novembre
18h45 en direct je recevrai la patrie
que j'enterre t patridge internet de
liste lrm à plaisir la semaine suivante
ce sera à grégory pas peu lui aussi
candidat à guyancourt pour lr em hell
n'oubliez pas que la campagne est aussi
à suivre sur notre site internet et via
notre application mobile très bien la
soirée
[Musique]